[Music]
going to Disneyland is a dream come true
whether you are a child or a grown-up
but taking a break isn't always as easy
as it seems
from crazy rules that you should never
break two mistakes that you should never
make you'll learn about everything you
need to know to have a Disney day make
sure you watch this video until the end
to know what happened when Snow White
had a stalker if you love Disney as much
as we do don't forget to subscribe to
our Channel and please give this video a
big thumbs up today we are showing you
10 things you should never do at
Disneyland
don't be unimpressed every child dreams
of one day meeting their favorite
characters and go on a ride while
spending time with their families and
Disneyland is where the magic happens
this is why many parents decide to
surprise their kids and tell them that
they are going to the most popular theme
park in the world and when they film
their little family their tears of joy
are there for the world to see however
there was one girl who was not impressed
at all and her name was Chloe when her
parents told her that they were going to
spend three magical days on vacation her
sisters started crying
but the little girl couldn't care less
this is how she became the popular meme
side-eyeing Chloe it's sad to think that
this child was not impressed by
Disneyland it's such a young age because
begging your parents to go on vacation
there is part of the magic we could even
say that wanting something makes us feel
better than actually getting something
and now that we are grownups and have
more responsibilities we would like our
parents to give us that chance to take a
break for free more than ever
fortunately Chloe learned this in the
best way when she went to Disneyland a
second time she couldn't be happier we
guess that it means that she loved going
there the first time don't take selfies
when you get the chance to meet the most
beautiful Disney Princesses in the world
you would love to take a lot of pictures
with them after all most of us will only
be there for a few days and we want the
memories to last forever how
we hope that you won't be meeting too
many Disney characters at the same time
because you won't have the right to use
a selfie stick that's right they have
been banned from the park as you can
read it in the rules online you will
have to rely on your arm and we hope
that it will be very long if you want to
see everything a Disney spokeswoman
explained that they strive to provide a
great experience for the entire family
but the selfie sticks have become a
growing safety concern for both their
guests and cast you might think that
selfie sticks can't do any harm unless
you hit someone repeatedly with it but
there was actually one person to blame
in this story a customer decided to use
a selfie stick on a roller coaster and
the ride ended up being shut for an hour
this is probably why all the selfie
sticks are now confiscated and kept at
security and we think that it is a good
opportunity to look at all the things
around us instead of looking at the
world through our smartphones don't grow
up too fast
Disneyland was the best place in the
world when we were kids and as grown-ups
it could still be yes we know that there
is actually someone in the Mickey Mouse
costume and that to ours is too long to
wait in line to go on a ride you'll also
notice that castles are really not that
tall and you don't fit anywhere anymore
and that being there on your own is like
being lost in a maze yes Disney is not
made for anyone over 14 years old but
these are not reasons why you shouldn't
have fun you are probably the one who
paid to go there this time so enjoy this
experience as much as you can instead of
ignoring the Disney Princesses or
waiting for them to approach you talk to
them they are grownups too and they will
probably have something interesting to
say everything might look different but
this new point of view could be even
more interesting you can also find out
more about restaurants hotels and rides
that you would like to try as a grownup
you will love to ride the rock and
roller coaster starring Aerosmith and
the twilight zone tower terror and then
eat roast lamb while watching belly
dancers at restaurant Marrakesh magic
still exists as long as you can believe
in it don't forget your Fastpass
the
best thing to do is to visit Disneyland
when there are not a lot of people there
but it is not always possible people
don't go on vacation during the summer
Christmas break and spring break because
they like to be surrounded by a lot of
people they do it because that's the
only time when they have the chance
sometimes there are so many people out
there that you are lucky to go on three
rides in one day during the worst days
you can wait at least an hour for a ride
and even up to two hours and there will
be a line again if you ever want to eat
or go to the bathroom this is why you
must get fast paths to make things a
little better the service is included in
the price of theme park admission and
you can get up to three selections for
each day but to go on the best rides at
the best time you'll have to plan up to
30 days in advance with a ticket and 60
prior to check-in if you stay at a hotel
however don't think that you can miss
your Fastpass window if you are too late
or too early you won't have the chance
to go on a ride a Fast Pass is a
privilege so make sure that you use it
the right way don't be rude to cast
members we understand that you spent two
hours waiting in line to go on Radiator
Springs racers or maybe you wanted to
meet Cinderella and she had to go on a
break before you could even go near her
and we were all upset when we realized
that we barely did anything that day
because there were too many people but
none of these things are a good reason
to be rude to cast members they are
doing their best and they don't like it
either when there are too many people
and they have probably met a lot of
angry customers before you so you don't
want to be the next one the cast member
will always keep a smile on their face
and will never break character no matter
what happens the best thing you can do
is make an effort to smile back some
people say that working at Disney World
and being around children and their
parents all day every day taught them
how not to raise their children some of
them even say that they often leave work
in tears and if you ever hear a cast
member tell someone to have a Disney day
it means that they have been dealing
with a difficult customer you don't want
to be that person cast members are doing
a lot of things for you so never forget
to be nice to them don't wear a costume
little girls wish they could become a
Disney Princess and the young boys hope
they will grow up to be just like their
favorite heroes Disneyland is the best
place to not only meet our favorite
characters but also be like them but
unfortunately that won't be happening if
you are an adult
that's because anyone over 14 years old
doesn't have the right to wear a costume
guests don't have the right to wear a
mask or even a cape if the length goes
below the waist if you ever go to the
theme park wearing some of these things
they have the right to deny admission or
ask you to remove the costume even when
dressing for special events grown-ups
don't have the right to pose for
pictures or sign autographs for other
guests and their costumes can't reach
the ground we understand these rules
after all we wouldn't want a prince not
so charming to earn the trust of a child
they don't know but it is still sad to
think that we will never get the chance
to become a true Disney Princess and
don't worry there are still some things
you can do accessories like transparent
wings plastic lightsabers and tutus are
acceptable and you can also wear a theme
shirt or a hat Disney is not so bad
after all
when you think about this don't point
with one finger if you are just a guest
you won't get in trouble for doing this
but if you are a cast member you have to
follow this rule some of you might have
already noticed this strange gesture
when you asked where your favorite ride
was and if you are wondering what it is
it is the Disney point everyone who
works at Disney is required to do all
pointing with two fingers some people
thought that it was a tribute to Walt
Disney's smoking habit and people claim
that in some old photos you could
actually see him pointing with a
cigarette between his two fingers but
don't worry they have a better reason to
explain this it is still a homage to
Disney but it is actually because he
thought that it was less rude that's
because this gesture is perceived more
negatively in other cultures class
members want to avoid any
misunderstandings when they are giving
directions so they use two fingers
instead and if you think that they are
not taking this seriously you would be
wrong a girl who worked as a Disney
Princess claimed that she was fired
because she didn't use
Disney point when giving directions so
next time you see a cast member pointing
with two fingers you'll know that they
know how to do their jobs
don't cheat the height limits no matter
how young we were we wanted to go on all
the rides and after waiting two hours in
line we didn't want to miss that chance
to ride the California screamin this is
why many kids try to cheat the height
limit by pretending that they are a
little taller by standing on their toes
when they see that they are too short
many parents even encourage them by
putting napkins in their shoes or
bullying the operator into letting their
child board the ride but all these
minimum height restrictions are not
there for nothing if the body of a child
is too small they could easily fall or
be ejected from moving rides even if
they are tall enough it is important to
note that the height minimum requirement
is dangerously low because it is only
measured by operators those who barely
meet the height limit are at higher risk
of being harmed on the ride but that's
not the only risk sometimes the problem
is that the ride could be too stressful
physically and emotionally so there is a
minimum age requirement instead but once
again you don't want to put your child
at risk when the limit is already too
low waiting an hour in line for nothing
is better than spending days at the
hospital because you fell from the ride
don't stalk the Disney Princesses they
might have the chance to be the most
beautiful women in the world but don't
think that their job is easy being too
pretty comes with a lot of disadvantages
including teenagers giving them their
phone numbers many men getting down on
one knee or fathers flirting with the
princesses while their wife is right
next to them don't forget that these
young women are only there to do their
job and they are not really interested
in you at all and Snow White is probably
the unluckiest of them all because she
is the one who met the weirdest stalker
she's had on reddit that for several
weeks a very old man would come to the
park to see her and tried to kiss her he
quickly realized that she was the only
girl with brown eyes which meant that
she was the true Snow White but when she
had a day off on Saturday and that the
man saw another woman in the costume he
was really upset so the next time
the real snow-white showed up he told
her that he would get rid of all the
snow whites with blue eyes so they could
stay together forever as you can imagine
the young woman freaked out called
security and his annual pass was revoked
and this is why Disney princesses don't
like it when you stalk them don't forget
to smile when you are in the most
magical place in the world the most
important thing that you should not
forget is to smile unless you live next
to Disneyland you probably won't have
the chance to go there again before a
long time so you want to make sure that
you take the time to appreciate
everything around you however there is
one little girl who couldn't care less
when she saw a Disney princess and she
thought that food was more important
when Kailen was eating mac and cheese at
a Disney theme park
Snow White decided to talk to her her
parents immediately took their phones to
film this amazing opportunity and they
were surprised by Kaitlyn's reaction she
had better things to do so she didn't
say anything and simply turned away Snow
White asked her to smile but this young
girl just looked disappointed
don't worry Kayla we totally understand
we know that mac and cheese is the most
important thing in the world and you
don't want anyone to ruin this moment
but at least we can say that she made
the whole world smile when they saw this
video is there any other thing that we
should never do at Disneyland don't
forget to tell us what it is in the
comments section down below we love to
know what you think and that's it for 10
things you should never do at Disneyland
for more stories like this make sure to
watch 10 strange requirements to work as
a Disney Princess thanks for watching
and see you next time
[Music]